[Musique]
à vos feutre ciseaux confectionner les
petits et les grands ont pu réaliser des
masques et des costumes pour le jour
d'halloween en compagnie de leurs
parents les enfants se sont imaginés en
vampires sorcières et autres outils et
issoire
tous
gd de repérer du faux seins et j'ai une
robe de sorcier sur deux après midi les
ateliers ou accueilli 30 cents
participants enfants et parents couru on
accepte toute la famille avec tous les
membres des enfants tous les tranches
d'âge et parce que ici un organisme pour
chaque enfant quelque chose donc il ya
le coloriage il ya les ateliers création
des masques pour les plus grands il ya
les costumes pour les mamans et les
grands enfants donc je pense c'est ça
qui facilite le lait venise et la
participation des familles une fois les
caps et les robes essayé puis ajuster
les petits gourmands sont impatients
d'être le jour j parce que on peut
sortir dehors pour aller demander des
bonbons
on peut aller chercher des bonbons ont
fait part à aux gens les enfants
pourront arborer leurs déguisements
mardi 31 octobre lors du défilé
d'halloween à l'estaminet
[Musique]